big tech employees are not the only
partisan democrats right now
pretending to be non-partisan did you
watch joe biden's town hall the other
night probably not
who would have so this was on nbc
and it was a town hall with undecided
voters
now the the undecided voters come out
and they ask these softball questions to
biden
and this is supposed to be a nice fair
non-partisan event right
the trouble is some of those undecided
voters looked familiar
some people at the washington free
beacon went through some of the previous
town halls
some of the previous news clips found
out that those undecided voters
previously
had identified themselves as joe biden
voters so it opens up
on october 5th just yesterday two days
ago welcome back
welcome back miami and the town hall
meeting with former vice president joe
biden taking questions from undecided
voters
peter gonzalez has next question welcome
to miami mr vice president um
i was born in hartford connecticut and
i've been living in coral gables for the
last
20 plus years we get four more years of
treatment
august 21st he says future attracting
younger voters
who voted for hillary clinton four years
ago but has voted republican
in the past what's your question for mr
biden mr vice president
things uh you know that that joe biden
said during his speech that resonates
same guy says he's voting for biden
october 21st
what defines america's possibility mateo
gomez joins us now
uh first-time voter came to the us from
colombia at age two welcome
spent a lot of october thank you lester
for the introduction
after watching the debate matteo gomez
told us he really didn't
got a whole lot out of it and it really
did not do a lot to help
him if you had to pull the trigger and
vote for someone tomorrow
how would you vote september 30th he's
going to vote for bible
because just how unpresidential the
whole entire debate was
so we've now got three allegedly
undecided voters on
nbc who are all self-described
joe biden voters so it's a it's a farce
it's not real
it's a show it is a
total performance of lies
that could be the subtitle of the
election
they're all they're all pretending look
we're not really political
i love this when my friend my it's
always my liberal friends who tell me
this
they say you know look i'm not really
political me look i'm
kind of a moderate actually i just think
we should have abortion on demand
i think that experts should make all of
our political decisions i think we need
socialist health care
i think we need to raise taxes on the
rich and i think we need open borders
look i'm not political
that's just common sense this is what
they do when they say they're going to
take away guns usually for public health
right they pretend it's not political
they say
look i'm not trying to get into politics
i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to get rid of your second
amendment or whatever that thing is you
like i'm just
i'm just talking about common sense gun
reform just common sense
and i'm sure by the way that their views
are common sense
if you are a liberal who believes that
liberalism is the only
political view that it is legitimate to
hold
but for the rest of us who are not
liberals then we look at it and we say
uh no that's not common sense actually
seems very
nonsensical now there is good news here
though
because as the left puts on this
performance about the
lack of politics the non-partisan people
the people who are
independent for the actual undecided
voters
trump is doing great for the actual
undecided voters
issue by issue everything stacks against
joe biden new study was released last
week
that showed 66 to 70 percent
of likely voters in five battleground
states
support school choice publicly funded
school choice school choice is a huge
winning issue for republicans we should
talk about it all the time because joe
biden totally opposes it
donald trump totally supports it this is
from the manhattan institute
which commissioned this survey added it
on to a poll from rasmussen
this was conducted in pennsylvania ohio
wisconsin michigan
north carolina all these battleground
states joe biden
has a very very negative view
of school choice and so the point is
if i'm president betsy devos's whole
notion from charter schools to this are
gone
all gone i actually asked secretary
devos about this when she came on the
verdict podcast
with um with me and senator cruz you can
check out that episode as well
now why are democrats doing this it's so
unpopular
they're doing this because they're in
bed with the teachers unions the
teachers unions
are part of their constituency they in
some
in some parts own the democratic party
so they're not allowed to support school
choice even though seventy percent of
people support
trump and the republicans should run
hard on this if you enjoyed that video
and i would hope that you did please be
sure to hit the subscribe button
so that all of the befuddled radicals
wading through the wasteland
of youtube knows where they can get the
truth
thanks